انا اريد ان اتحرك الى المنطقه الاخرى
لاضعك في الصوره حيث الان في هذه اللحظات
تشاهد الفريق السعودي فريق الدفاع المدني
السعودي وصل الى هذه المنطقه
برفقته مسؤولي مركز الملك سلمان لمباشره
العمل امام هذا المبنى مباشره في هذه
اللحظات حيث يتم العمل بعد اجتماعات مع
الجانب التركي وتحديدا افاد الجهه المنظمه
لعمل الجهات كامله يتم العمل على التنسيق
وتم وضع الفريق السعودي في مدينه غازي
عنتاب شاهد هذا هو الاجتماع كما شاهدته
ويتم العمل من قبل هؤلاء هم افراد من
الدفاع المدني السعودي الذين يعملون
بجانبا بنجنب بجانب الاطقم التركيه مباشره
امام هذا المبنى الذي هو في خلفي ويتم
العمل على
تنقيبه ومحاوله استخراج
في هذه
اللحظات في غازي عنتاب المدينه التي سيبدا
منها الفريق السعودي عمله
وبدا فعليا كما تشاهدين في الصوره في هذه
اللحظات في غازي عنتاب في المدينه
والاجزاء المتضرره بشكل كبير جدا من هذا
الزلزال الذي ضرب تركيا وغازي عنتاب هي
واحده من اكثر المناطق تضررا اما ان كان
عن
في الجانب
المنازل التي سقطت وسويت بالارض او حتى في
الجانب الانساني فهذا الفريق السعودي
يتواجد معه طاقم اغاثي بالاضافه الى طاقم
انقاذ وايضا يتواجد معه مساعدات كبيره جدا
نتحدث عن
مساعدات اغاثيه ايوائيه لكافه الاشخاص
الذين هم ليس لديهم ماوى